the uncanny valley strikes back but
maybe it didn't have to
during the final moments of the
mandalorian second season finale
we got the return of the jedi luke
skywalker that is
for any long time star wars fan the
identity of the mysterious cloaked jedi
that absolutely rips through off
gideon's dark troopers became obvious
long before he revealed his
technologically de-aged face
the green lightsaber is just too iconic
as is the single black glove concealing
his prosthetic hand
however as exciting as it is to see luke
holding grogu
the first new member of yoda's race
we've seen since seattle showed up in
the prequel trilogy
the experience was bittersweet for a lot
of people
much like grand moff tarkin and princess
leia's appearance in rogue one a star
wars story
luke skywalker didn't quite look like
luke skywalker
indeed peter cushing did not portray
grand moff tarkin in rogue one
nor was carrie fisher on set as princess
leia organa
similarly luke skywalker was not mark
hamill on the mandalorian but rather
another actor named max lloyd jones
sporting a hokey cgi-crafted mark hamill
face
that was digitally painted on in most
cases fans will bemoan the use of this
kind of technology to the point of
wishing their favorite character did not
appear at all
in the case of luke skywalker however
what fans want is a recast
those same fans have a very specific
actor in mind to take over last jedi
duties
sebastian stan this is not the first
time people have noticed that sebastian
stan and mark hamill bear a striking
resemblance to one another
on may 10 2016 live for films tweeted a
picture of hamel a skywalker
next to a photo of sebastian stan's face
superimposed over it
and the likeness is quote uncanny in a
good way for once
in fact the similarity is so clear that
hamill himself retweeted the image
adding
five o'clock shadow luke with dreamboat
gazepower collect them all
at rhode island comic con in 2017 stan
was asked about the similarity between
him and hamill he responded i just want
to say here that anytime anyone would
like to call me and ask me about luke
skywalker
i'd be very happy in short fans had
every reason to believe that their wish
upon a star from a galaxy
far far away would come true hamel
enjoyed the comparison and stan was
quite obviously
up for the challenge so when instead of
stan's face they saw cgi hamill instead
fans were displeased
twitter user djsn81 did not mince words
when writing
jesus christ said just you sebastian
stand for luke
rather than this janky ps3 cutscene
looking version we got
tarkin layer and now this it doesn't
work
stop it user luchi produce was a little
kinder
but made the more important point by
writing cgi looked good for what we got
but if luke is going to be in the show
now i hope they get sebastian stan to
play him
simply put there is a limit to how long
people will accept a cgi face in a
live-action world
in other words if luke is meant to be a
big part of the mandalorian's third
season
there's going to have to be a better
long-term solution or as p
rabbit holes put it just get sebastian
stan to play luke for
sake they're basically clones the
cloners on kamino were unavailable for
comment
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite star wars tv shows and
movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one